[Music]
Utah is now leading a national debate
over how to raise children a new law
that makes the state the first to
officially support free-range parenting
that concept encourages kids to be
independent by offering less parental
supervision
Utah's law prevents parents from being
prosecuted for allowing kids to roam on
their own Jamie yuccas shows how the
concept may be catching on in other
states
Melissa Butler isn't just a mom she's
master of this three-ring mourning
circus helping her seven and
nine-year-old get ready and off to
school walking together she expects they
will get to class safely obviously most
the kids in this neighborhood do walk to
school on their own walk home on their
own that frees up Butler to turn her
attention to her two-year-old and some
juice I just think man if I had to
physically take my children everywhere
that they went I don't know that I would
have time for anything
Butler is part of a push for so-called
free-range parenting
under the new law that went into effect
in Utah on Tuesday she's protected from
being charged with neglect for allowing
her kids to do activities like go to the
park or ride their bikes alone other
states are now considering free range
parenting laws including New York and
New Jersey a similar measure failed in
Arkansas as legislature but lawmakers
there say they may now try to bring it
back Utah Republican state
representative Brad da sponsored the
original free range parenting bill
there's arguments on both sides nobody
wants to see it kid abducted but
everybody wants a kid to be a kid the
idea isn't without controversy in 2015 a
Maryland couple was investigated by
Child Protective Services when they
allowed their than ten and six-year-old
kids to walk home alone from a park and
in 2008 Lenore's can Daisy was called
world worst mom for letting her then
nine-year-old son ride the New York City
subway alone she's credited with
jump-starting the free range parenting
movement as much as I want to push
parents to trust themselves when they
think their kid is ready they should be
allowed to send them out they also have
to know their decisions are not going to
be second-guess
by the authorities critics say the new
law can have unintended consequences a
column and last month's Atlantic
highlighted how loser child supervision
laws could compromise the safety of
children from underprivileged families
who may be more prone to abuse or
neglect Butler says parents should have
the freedom to make their own decisions
as long as the child is you know healthy
happy and cared for you know we need to
stop trying to micromanage other parents
parenting decisions for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Salt Lake City Utah I think
it's a parental decision I really do you
know when when I was growing up back in
the day you could get on your bicycle
ride all around the neighborhood at very
young ages but I think the times are
different that's I think parents should
be able to decide they should be able to
live - if you live in a city or a world
military I got one military bases so we
were all locked in so it was named right
around on a bike there I I wouldn't want
kids doing what I did when I grew up
more on that later you